two different agendas that operator
cares about short-term results
a startup needs to be like a baby those
first three years you have to coddle
and be patient
[Applause]
you got your
i just perspective to be happy don't you
want to be happy
[Music]
mark laurie the president and ceo of
walmart u.s
e-commerce and founder and ceo of
debt.com
and he's a serial entrepreneur mark was
appointed in 2016
to lead walmart's ecom when his company
jet.com was acquired
in this role he accelerates walmart's
e-commerce growth and customer reach
leading walmart.com
leadingwalmart.comanandajet.com
mark was named ian wise entrepreneur of
the year
and fortune's smartest people in
technology
welcome mark we're feeling solid first
of all you look great are you
racing jerry rice again i don't know why
you look so handsome
no no you're not seeing down here you
know the covid 19 is for real
yeah the cove at 19. has completely
outpaced the freshman 15 for most of my
friends and family
um mark thank you for being on obviously
we had a very long session on my podcast
so i know a lot of people
in the audience have gotten that context
but i also know a lot of people listen
to marketing for now that have no clue
about my podcast so three minutes on
your entrepreneurial journey
context the 182nd 242nd version of
kids selling baseball cards to where you
are now at walmart
yeah when i was four years old i uh
people asked what i wanted to be the
teacher and i wrote this thing up that
said i want to be
a farmer because they grow stuff from
nothing in crayon and my mom kept it
and that basically sums up you know
everything you know i i love creating
stuff from nothing i did every
entrepreneurial business you could think
about as a kid
mowing lawns weeds newspapers recycle
wash cars by the way that's
that's that's that's pulling weeds in
new jersey not selling weed as a kid
right i just want to make sure everybody
heard you
exactly no you're from jurors so
anything's possible
and then you know went to college and uh
there wasn't really the startup scene so
when i graduated college
i went to work for a bank you know it's
uh
i wish i could have worked for a startup
but it wasn't really a thing
and then um worked in banking for about
six seven years
was doing really well knew i didn't want
to be in banking forever the
startup scene was starting to heat up
this is late 90s and
decided one day to just quit and and
start a company
and took some risk and the rest is
history i've done four startups sold
built and sold four startups and the
last two one was to amazon
was quit c uh so holding company for
doctors.com wag.com
sold to amazon back in 2011. started
jet.com sold that to walmart uh uh
four years ago can you give us the five
seconds
version of how you got your inventory
for diapers.com which is a brand a lot
of people know
yeah we started diapers.com yeah proctor
and gamble
huggies you know kimberly clark uh
pampers and huggies the two main diaper
brands could not get them direct from
the manufacturer
for two years they would not sell us so
the only way to get diapers was to go to
the wholesale clubs and buy them
and so we'd go to the wholesale club buy
them label them ship them out the
problem was we lost
money on every box of diapers we sold um
knowing
full well that one day if we got big
enough the manufacturer would sell us
direct
and although i mean they eventually did
but only because
you know the wholesale club i think was
bj's we would clear them out of every
single box of diapers
and they got so frustrated that they
called the manufacturer and said can you
please sell these guys direct because
they're killing
and the manufacturers said at the time
we still don't believe in your business
model we don't believe in selling
diapers online
but we'll sell you because bj's is an
important client of ours
and that was the only reason and you
know fast forward
you know 10 years later procter gamble
is basically saying that they think that
you know why would anybody buy diapers
anywhere but online why would they go in
a store
and so it's a very quick turnaround you
know you sell a company to amazon
and then you come back almost a decade
later and you sell one to walmart
and and my question is
how do you how do you bring your
entrepreneurialism
to the table in those environments right
one thing i've been impressed with so
you know being a fan of your execution
from afar we didn't know each other
during this time but we were doing our
things in jersey and i would always
kind of root for you because there's so
few people who are actually operators
you know by the way back to real
entrepreneurs versus not a lot of
real entrepreneurs give up when they
can't get the inventory because the
business plan said you have to buy the
product
you know that's what i admired i uh
so when i saw the jet.com this me
personally official
you know point of view i was like okay
what a brilliant he played the model
again
he went to the other place is he really
going to be able to impact that place
because
unlike the first place the dna is
matched way more
i'm real curious as a i'm a fake the way
people watch basketball is the way i
watch
business we have just jeff smith coming
up soon who is also back to that whole
ecosystem
an incredible executive at j j and as he
went into his entrepreneurial world
hey i care about him as a human and was
rooting for him but also curious to see
that kind of
athlete who dominated in that one game
how is he gonna be like what's he gonna
learn what's he gonna be good at and not
gonna i love that [ __ ]
i was real i really was like ooh can
walmart
ingest that organ can that body ingest
that organ
and what's gonna happen and will jet.com
eventually become walmart.com
some of these stories have played out
we've never talked about this even
though in the last couple years we've
gotten to know each other
talk me through being an entrepreneur
operator in such a conglomerate
and what did it play out better than you
thought like
i'm sure you were the body as well
you know just using your common sense i
already kind of got your quick answer
i'm fascinated by this part
because this usually doesn't work out
it's seemingly i don't have the details
is working out talking me through it
yeah no it's a it's a great lesson for
big companies making acquisitions of
startups i think
you know when when we sold the company
to amazon
um they were like hey you continue to
keep doing your thing because that's
what you want to do right as an
entrepreneur you just want to keep doing
your thing we'll leave you alone
and i think a lot of big companies think
that entrepreneurs want to be just keep
doing their thing and be left alone
that's not necessarily the case when you
have a platform as big as amazon or as
big as walmart
you want to be able to impact the
mothership and really be able to help
drive
massive change much bigger than you can
do on your own so
in the case of amazon they left us alone
they said keep doing your thing
you guys will be happy just doing your
thing right and we're like no
but nothing changed with walmart i had
learned that lesson and
talking to doug mcmillan the ceo at the
time who still is
um really started to to build uh
you know the the core values of the
relationship from the ground up you know
starting with trust and we built a lot
of trust in a very short period of time
and i told doug if you really want um
you know jet
and me and the team to to help walmart
and help
you know drive uh change then we would
be up for that if you just want to buy
us and leave
us alone and have us do our thing we're
not interested
we've done that already and i don't want
to play that dance again
exactly and so when doug and the board
came back and said hey we want to give
you and your team
sort of the keys to e-commerce here at
walmart um
we we think that you know you and the
team
could really help make a big impact here
and i think that was the key
it was as simple as that it was
basically empowering me and the team
to to go and make change a little bit
more of a hardball question how do you
feel it's going on quote-unquote closing
the gap between
amazon.com and walmart.com i mean i i
think it's going really well
there's still a big gap there but if you
look at where we were four years ago
when i joined
versus you know where where we are today
uh
i'm quite proud of the progress the team
has made
where where have you advanced more than
you anticipated you're a smart dude i've
really
come to admire you where you advanced
more
than you thought and where have you
fallen short more than you thought if i
went into a time machine
and had a glass of wine with 48 months
ago mark yeah i mean
as an entrepreneur when i say fall short
you know i had
you know really big uh audacious goals
set
for ourselves and the team when we came
in uh you know shoot for the stars and
land on the moon sort of thing so yeah i
mean
i think it was harder than i expected
even though i expected it to be hard
it's hard
it's hard to move an aircraft carrier
and change direction
um with that being said you know i i'm
surprised at how much we've been able to
innovate
inside of a big company you know we
started this thing called store number
eight which is an umbrella
for startups that we built inside of
walmart and we've been able to build a
bunch of these startups
that are wholly owned by walmart and
then infuse them back in the business
and i
was a great lesson i'd recommend it for
any big company
you know it's really hard to build a
startup inside of a business when the
when they're being managed by the
operators of the business because and
positive
two different agendas that operator
cares about short-term results
a startup needs to be like a baby those
first three years you have to coddle
and be patient yes exactly so if you can
carve it out
and give it capital and and and let it
act like a startup and then in a couple
years when it's got traction
the business then raises their hand and
says yeah i i would love that to be part
of my business and you're like okay
here you go you know just take the
winners and uh and it's worked out
really well we built some businesses we
infused them back in the business
um i think the whole in-home delivery
is is is a great example um delivering
directly into people's refrigerators
um i think walmart plus launch i think
um you know that was uh you know a way
for walmart to leverage their unique
assets to do something that only walmart
can do
um so
what um what's your biggest learning
from covid i'm just really excited to
get into your mind for a second here
what's your biggest aha and what's your
biggest
reaffirmation your biggest [ __ ] i didn't
see that wow this is cool
and your biggest i knew it i told i just
knew it
and look how obvious it is now yeah
i i had really early on as soon as you
know in in march
i was was sort of fascinated with with
this pandemic and sort of
built built my own sort of model to
predict what was going to happen
yes i was getting that text that was
wild bro i thought i was like oh mark's
way more math nerdy than i think i
realized that was cool
i forgot about that was a highlight for
me i was waiting for those texts
i started it i mean that i am a sort of
math nerd you know that's how i
you know started when i was younger is
math and stuff that sort of stuff so um
i just thought you were rusty yeah
definitely rusty and definitely rest
no but uh sometimes you know you have to
like dig deep
i was reading all kinds of stuff as
everybody else was and you've seen all
these
contradictory things you didn't know
what to believe and i just felt like
this was one of those times to kind of
dive deep
and kind of model and figure it out
yourself and i think that was that was
super helpful
for just planning purposes to kind of
understand what was going to happen
when and and what the risks and
opportunities were there so
i think that was a great lesson in in
just you know knowing when to
to sort of dive deep into something it
happens in in business every day
you're you're in a leadership position
and you're typically you know just
staying at at you know uh
mile mile high and then every once in a
while you got to know when is the time
to sort of dig deep and rip something
apart
and so that was a that was a great
lesson for me in in in doing that so
um i had a a different perspective on
covet i kind of had a little bit
more knowledge as to where what was
happening and where it was going
um and uh and what about what about the
biggest affirmation like what did you
just
what have you seen from consumer
behavior business that you were like yep
and i'm glad other people see it now too
i mean certainly with ecom i mean it
pulled e-commerce
probably for maybe three four years um
in terms of that and i think it'll
that'll continue to happen um but
there's lots of new habits
that that people have formed you know as
a result trends that were going to
happen naturally
but we're going to take a lot longer and
i think in in lots of industries
you're seeing that and being able to
recognize um
you know those opportunities is is key
for any successful entrepreneur thinking
about doing a new business
where's the puck going uh as opposed to
where it's been yeah
mark i really appreciate you thanks for
figuring out the very difficult
technical difficulties you had which
allowed you to jam with us i really
appreciate your time continued success
yeah thanks gary it was a lot of fun see
you youtube watcher what's up it's
garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you